ROMAN NURIK: All right everyone,
and hello, and
welcome to Android Design in
Action, the first episode of
the year 2013.
My name is Roman Nurik.
ADAM KOCH: Hey guys,
happy new year.
Adam Koch here.
NICK BUTCHER: And hi,
Nick Butcher.
I'm joining you from sunny
California, rather than
London, as it may say below.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah,
it says London.
We didn't have time to change
the name card below Nick.
It does say London, but he is
actually broadcasting from
Mountain View, California.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
We're not very good with
Photoshop yet.
ROMAN NURIK: So today, our
episode is going to be a
little bit of both design and
development, not too much
development.
You won't see any code.
You'll see maybe a few little
pointers to things here and
there, but it'll be mostly for
designers, but developers
should definitely
pay attention.
So today's episode is titled
Iterative Improvements, and
what that means is we're going
to take a look at a very bare
bones starting point app--
and this is not a real app, it's
just a hypothetical app--
and we'll see how over the
course of a few key steps, we
can get it from a point which
is kind of nothing to be
talked about, kind of a really
uglyish app, it doesn't really
create a great reading
experience, to something
that's just a little
better than that.
Before we get started, do you
guys have any comments on--
well actually before that, the
type of app we're going to
talk about is a basic article
reader, not really an RSS
reader like Google Reader, but
basically something that has a
list of articles and the
article details.
Should we just get started?
Do you guys have any comments
you want to share
before we jump in?
NICK BUTCHER: No, let's
go straight in.
ADAM KOCH: Yeah, let's go.
ROMAN NURIK: All right.
Let's do it since we have
tons of slides.
So let's look at the
bare bones app.
So this is the starting point.
I'm sure many of you have seen
apps kind of like this in the
Play Store.
There are lots of issues
at play here.
First, it's kind of hard to tell
the different articles on
the left apart.
There's no action bar.
This is using the pre-Android
4.0, Android 3.0, title bar,
this has got the Legacy
menu button here.
All sorts of things
wrong with this.
And obviously, there's lots
of wrong spacing, metrics.
We'll talk about all the details
in a bit, but this is
kind of our starting point.
So like I said, we're going to
jump through a couple of
different steps and along the
way, we'll talk about what is
involved in each step and
how to actually do it.
So the first step is to change
to the Holo theme, and add an
action bar to your app.
So you can see here that the
Holo theme-- actually, the
Holo theme automatically gives
you an action bar by default.
But you have the action bar at
the top, and what that gives
you is that gives you a sense of
place into where you are in
the app and which app you're
in-- so you see the little
icon here--
as well as some basic actions
that are immediately
available on screen.
So things like refresh, if you
wanted to be able to refresh
the list of articles, as well
as an overflow, giving you
access to things that usually
you would see under the legacy
menu button.
ADAM KOCH: And just from a
developer standpoint, it's
really a matter of enabling a
target SDK version for your
application in your manifest of,
I think, 11 or above, but
obviously, we recommend
targeting the latest platform
version where you can.
So in this case, we just put
down here a little note that
says target SDK version of 17.
And in addition, there's a theme
that you can set for
Holo, so in this case, it's
Theme.Holo Light Dark Action
Bar, so that's the light theme
down bottom, with a dark
action bar at the top.
NICK BUTCHER: And one really
little thing to pick out here
is if you take a look at the
background color on here, you
see it's changed from pretty
much pure white to a slightly
off white, which is part of
the Holo palette really.
And there's really good reasons
that we selected these
base colors for the base themes
which you inherit from,
because that white on mobile
can be a searingly bright
color, which you want to use
quite sparingly, and it's not
very great for the
background color.
So it's a subtle change, but
it instantly makes the app
easier to read.
ROMAN NURIK: For sure.
And we've kept that throughout,
so you'll see the
evolution of this design with
more branding elements and
things like that, and we've
kept that default color.
So let's move on.
What's the next step?
We have an action bar, we
have the Holo theme.
That gives you a little bit,
that improves the visual
design a little bit, but
what's the next step?
So the next step is to customize
the action bar and
give your app a little
touch of branding.
So you'll see here that
we've chosen an
orange color palette.
And again, this is
really up to you.
If you have an existing service,
an existing color
scheme for your brand,
introduce it.
This is the best place, I'd say,
in your app to introduce
branding, is the action bar
since it's a key structural
element, yet at the same time,
it's a key area to
differentiate.
And then the little icon we
chose here, this is actually
not a standard launcher icon.
This is a custom icon
for the action bar.
And so remember that you don't
necessarily have to have your
exact pixel for pixel launcher
icon in the action bar.
You can customize it so that it
looks good in the context
of the action bar.
And so the launcher icon for
this app would probably be an
orange circle with a white y,
but we decided that this
inverted color scheme would
look good here.
And you'll also notice that
we've introduced some of the
same color scheme elements
throughout the content.
By the way, I should
preface that.
All the content here
is meat specific.
It's a bunch of bacon,
chicken, and steaks.
This is just kind of example
content, so it's--
ADAM KOCH: Pretty
bacon-friendly
color scheme, actually.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, a very
bacon-oriented reading
experience.
ADAM KOCH: Yes.
NICK BUTCHER: I've not had
breakfast yet, and it's making
me very hungry.
ROMAN NURIK: What is it, 7:30
AM over there, Nick?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
ROMAN NURIK: So links and other
things throughout are
accented with this orange,
so that's the next step.
And then--
ADAM KOCH: Yeah, and then
I guess from a developer
standpoint--
I think actually, Nick, you had
some blog posts up on the
developer blog that outlined
some ways to theme the action
bar, but there's also a great
tool called the Action Bar
Style Generator.
If you just Google for it,
you'll find that, which
generates all those things for
you, so you don't have to
worry about all the different
types of elements and
attributes that you
need to style.
NICK BUTCHER: Thanks very much
for that [INAUDIBLE].
ROMAN NURIK: All right,
moving on.
So the next step, and this
is one of the key
most important steps.
This is, I think, one of the
key ways in which polished
apps and apps with really good
fit and finish differentiate
from the less polished apps,
is the margins and the
spacing, the way they
treat white space.
And this is one of a UI
designer's best tools in
creating contrast
and readability.
Readability is the concept of
not necessarily legibility of
paragraphs and words, but
readability is the sense of,
given a block of text, how
easy is it for the eye to
consume that information.
And adding margins and
spaces is one of the
key ways to do that.
So you notice that from that
previous screen, we've tweaked
the spacing so that you can
better separate each article
in the list on the left from
its background and from the
other articles, as well as we've
added some standard 16dp
margins throughout the content
on the detail screen here.
ADAM KOCH: And you'll probably
hear us often mention the 48dp
rhythm from the design side, so
that's really what all of
this is based off.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, and we'll
show some red lines at the end
that show some of the
spacings that we use
on tablets as well.
And this is, again, one of
the key ways in which you
differentiate handset from
tablet to make sure that,
again, that readability,
that comfort in
reading is still there.
So let's move on unless,
Nick, you had any--
NICK BUTCHER: No.
It just instantly got more
breathing room, I think it's
so much easier to stand now.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
So the next step is another
important way in which you can
introduce consistency and a
strong rhythm in your app is
the way you treat photo
thumbnails.
So you'll notice that in the
previous version, these photos
were all jaggedy or lopsided.
They didn't have a strong
rhythm, because they had
different aspect ratios.
So one of the ways in which you
can alleviate this is to
introduce a different type of
scaling, and Adam could talk
about that, but basically you'll
notice here that all
the photos line up.
They're full bleed edge to edge,
and they introduce kind
of a strong, single line
in your design.
So it's very easy for the eye to
separate the text from the
image, and to separate the
images from each other since
there's kind of that light
separator there.
ADAM KOCH: Yeah, and then from
the developer side, there's an
attribute scale type, which you
can set to center crop,
where the framework will
actually do this for you.
Of course, if you're pulling
down an image from a server
side or something like that, you
could have the images come
down at the right size already,
but in many cases
that's not possible.
So this is actually a really
good way to make sure that
they're all lined up and
of the same size.
I really like this.
It really brings the images out
a little bit more, and as
you say, the lines really
make a huge difference
there on the left.
NICK BUTCHER: The before version
where you have the
uneven raggedness, the edge is
like a jagged tooth pattern.
It looks like you have these
gappy teeth, and it just isn't
right, [INAUDIBLE] very well.
That is a big improvement.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
What you want to avoid is, if
you look at your design or
your UI from a few feet away,
you don't want to see a New
York City skyline.
You want to see consistent
grids.
You want to see rectangular
And in some cases for really
complex, interesting UIs, you
probably want to go just a
little deeper than that.
You want to do some more
interesting things.
But at the very most basic
level, if you're simply
presenting a collection of
information, you want to make
sure that you're establishing
a grid, and establishing
single lines so that it's very
easy for the eye to follow the
flow of information.
OK, moving on.
I think the next step is one
of the biggest, and this is
something we've touched on a
million times in the show, but
typography.
In a moment you'll see the
difference that just a few
attributes can make in the
overall visual aesthetic, but
also just the ease in consuming
information.
So let's go to the next
section on typography.
So you'll notice that here--
and this is more like micro
typography, where we've looked
at the treatment of text at the
individual character level.
I guess it's a combination of
macro and micro, macro being
the typography that's creating
the general figures of text,
the general blocks of text.
In this case, we've looked at
the micro aspect of that.
So if we look in here to the
list screen, you'll notice
that in each of the articles,
the title stands
out a little more.
It's Roboto Bold Condensed.
And the subtitle, the "18
minutes ago by the author,"
that was made more muted since
that's less important
information.
Once your eye settles on a title
that you want to read
about, maybe at that point, you
then want to read about
the subtitle or you want to
find out who wrote that.
And so once your eye settles
on the title, then you can
make the small visual step to
look at who wrote it and when
it was published.
But this really cleanly
separates each individual
title from the subtitle
as well.
And then on the detail screen
here, we've used a similar
treatment for the title here.
We've again used Roboto
Condensed Bold.
But then for the text itself,
we've actually used a custom
font, it's called Rosario.
But this is generally
not necessary to
use a custom font.
You can use one of the Roboto
variants for body text.
But we found that in this case,
it may be possible to
introduce this custom font in
a light way, not using it
overly throughout the UI, not
making every single UI element
this custom font.
But in this case, it may
improve legibility.
So any thoughts on the
typography, guys?
NICK BUTCHER: You want to
talk about the line
spacing as well at all?
ROMAN NURIK: Sure.
So another important aspect
you should look at, when
changing fonts especially,
is the line spacing.
In typography terms,
it's the leading.
It's basically the space
between each line.
And this affects, again, that
readability aspect.
How easy is it for the eye to
move from one line to the next
as you get to the end of one
line, jumping over to the next
one and starting that?
So all these things-- the
spacing around the text, the
line spacing between each
line-- that's all very
important to the readability.
And so here we've used I think
a multiplier of 1.2.
But generally, if you feel that
your text is a little too
cramped, don't underestimate the
power of introducing a 1.1
or 1.2 line spacing.
ADAM KOCH: And from the
development side, there's two
attributes generally that you
want to look at here.
It's Android Family and
Android Line Spacing
Multiplier.
So those together allow you to
achieve an effect like this.
ROMAN NURIK: And I should
mention that for custom
fonts-- and again, use them very
sparingly in key areas
where it may improve the
experience for reading large
blocks of text.
For custom typefaces,
you may want to look
at Google Web Fonts.
Rosario, for example, is
available through Google Web
Fonts and it hints really,
really well on mobile.
So that's another key important
thing is you've got
to make sure to not just pick a
font based on what it looks
like on the web.
You want to actually try it out
on a few devices, and make
sure that it looks
really crisp.
Because some fonts, some TTF
files, don't actually have
really good hinting
instructions, and so when
they're taken down to smaller
sizes, they're not going to
look very good.
They're just going to
kind of be off and
not very well aligned.
So that's something that is
definitely important to try,
and not just on the web
but on mobile as well.
Shall we move on?
NICK BUTCHER: Well, I just want
to say, I think the use
of different font weights is
a very good way for giving
structure to your content.
I think exactly what Roman was
saying about how you want to
make this [INAUDIBLE]
18 minutes ago, see visually,
but be equally
legible if you need it.
Just by glancing at this
screenshot, if you look away
and look back, it just stands
out, the structure of the
content and what you want to
read first, and it's so much
easier to scan the page now.
[INAUDIBLE].
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
This concept of visual hierarchy
is very important.
You want to make sure to
establish a visual hierarchy
in terms of, what is the top
level item and then what are
its sub-items?
In this case, the top level
item is the title.
The title of the article is
basically the name that you
would put in the tree
for the article.
That would be its title.
So the subtitle, as well as its
body content, is kind of a
child of that, so that should
be lower in the visual
hierarchy, so it should stand
out a little less.
Again, once your eye hits the
title, then it could move on
to the sub-items in that tree
to go ahead and read details
about that.
All right, moving on?
So alternatively, we actually
created an alternative
presentation.
This is something that doesn't
work in every case.
And I think in this case
actually, it doesn't work
super well.
But alternatively, you could
combine photos and text.
This is something that a couple
of popular apps do now.
But what you could do is combine
photos and text.
Just make sure that, again,
your text lines up.
So here you'll notice that the
title still lines up with the
subtitle, and it lines up
with the body as well.
So that's, again, very important
to establish those
clear lines for alignment.
NICK BUTCHER: So have you used
a visual treatment behind the
text here to give it some
contrast because you don't
control the image?
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
So there's a little
bit here in the
sense of we use a gradient.
We've shown this in the past
with, I think it was
TripAdvisor's redesign.
Nick, you used that effect.
We used a gradient, a light
black gradient.
So it fades from about a 30%
or 40% opaque black to 0%
opaque black so that content
along the bottom has stronger
background protection.
So if the image itself--
let's say this image of a
steak-- if the whole image is
actually white, then you'll
still be able to read the text
because of that background
protection.
So since we're running sort of
low on time, let's start
flying through some of these.
So we also added a ViewPager
to make sure that you can
swipe between the
detail screens.
This is fairly straightforward
using the ViewPager from
Support Library.
NICK BUTCHER: It's [INAUDIBLE]
is well documented on the
design side.
ROMAN NURIK: And you should,
where possible, introduce this
into your detail view so that
you can very quickly swipe
between items.
So let's jump into tablet.
Let's take a flashback
to our Step Zero.
If you were to run that Step
Zero starting point on a
tablet, this is what
it would look like.
So you'd have two separate
screens that just make
horrible use of space.
You have all these large regions
of white space here at
the bottom.
You also very large
line lengths--
we'll talk about that--
which makes reading
really a pain.
So as you're reading the first
line here, here, here, here,
then it's time to go on
to the next line.
Your eye is trying to move to
the next line, but it's very
hard for it to find the next
line, because this text has
too long of a measure.
So we'll talk about how
to improve that.
ADAM KOCH: And of course, the
images are tiny in this
particular view.
So on a tablet, that's
not making very
good use of the space.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
Pretty terrible overall.
If this is your tablet
experience,
this is pretty bad.
You should fix it.
NICK BUTCHER: It's an
instant uninstall.
ROMAN NURIK: An instant
uninstall on the tablet,
that's right.
So let's say we were to fast
forward, and just use all
those tricks of spacing and
everything and see what that
would that look like
on the tablet.
It's much better, but still not
great, because you still
have those long lines.
You still have that image where
now the aspect ratio is
completely different from
the source material.
So you only see the very middle
strip of the image,
which is fine in this case.
ADAM KOCH: Doesn't look too
bad in this case, yeah.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, it's still
a strip of bacon.
You can't go wrong with that.
But you could do better
than this, right?
So the next step is to
create a two-pane UI.
So in this case, what we've
done here is we've simply
combined the master and
the detail into a
single two-pane UI.
And this is fairly
straightforward.
In Eclipse, you can do File,
New, Master Detail Flow to get
you the basics for this,
but there's also some
articles you can read.
ADAM KOCH: Yeah,
developers.Android.com/training
has two really good training
classes on that.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
So it's fairly straightforward
to do it these days.
There's a lot of prewritten
code for you.
It is fairly complex code if
you're just a beginner, but
it's File, New, and
you're done.
And you can read about
the details here in
these training articles.
So moving on.
How would we then
improve this?
So what we can do is now start
tweaking, again, the margins
and the spacing and
the different
dimensions on tablets.
So that when you open up the
same detail view on a tablet,
you'll actually get larger
text, for example.
You get more spacing on the
sides to, again, better
separate the figure from the
ground, better separate the
text from its background.
You can bump up font sizes.
You can bump up line spacing.
Again, lots of things you can
do here to make it better.
And it's fairly easy from the
development side as well.
ADAM KOCH: I mean hopefully,
when we are talking about the
phone side, you extracted all
of the different dimensions,
padding, spacing, into a
separate XML file, and then
you can choose when you want
to bump those up again, at
which screen size you want
to bump them up.
So in this example down in the
bottom here, it's at smallest
with 600dp, and then at 720dp
for seven- and ten-inch
tablets respectively.
But of course, it's up
to you when you want
to tweak those sizes.
This is just the standard and
what we would recommend for
looking at different sizes.
NICK BUTCHER: And you
can provide multiple
switchpoints, right?
So you can have different
metrics on a five-inch,
seven-inch, [INAUDIBLE].
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, for sure.
And actually, one that we don't
often talk about is
small devices.
So devices that have really
small screens, you may want to
tweak things even further
there, maybe even start
compressing information into
separate navigable sections.
If your user base is on small
devices, then again, that's
something that you want to do
using something like sw300 or
200dp, or values-small,
for example.
So let's actually look at some
of the metrics here, take a
quick sidebar.
And again, this still uses the
48dp rhythm in the sense that
things are generally multiples
of 48 or 16, and for smaller
sizes, we use 32, 16, 24,
8, things like that.
Powers of two and things
divisible by four, roughly.
So here's just some of
the quick examples.
Generous margins around
the content here.
I mean, 80dp.
If you're not using something
as large as 80 or 64dp for
margins on a tablet, then you
probably should be, since you
really want a lot of space so
that the eye can comfortably
read the content.
And then the font size here
is fairly large, 48sp's.
Let's also look at that
same alternative.
So again, with the photo
behind the text.
It's even more evident
here that there's
a background gradient.
But again, the key point here is
that you'll notice that the
alignment is still there.
The text still aligns so that
the eye can very quickly read.
We've been talking a
lot about reading.
If you're interested in reading
more about this, look
up macro typography, as
well as readability.
There's a lot of great articles
out there on how to
best create a very readable
experience.
Let's keep flying through.
So some extra credit
things that we did.
What could a notification
be like?
Let's say you're a blog author
or an author, and you're
posting stuff to this
bacon site.
Let's say that there's some
sort of background process
that says, the photo is
uploading, the text is uploading.
What could a nice
notification be?
You could get a notification
with a preview of the photo
that everything's
been uploaded.
And then when you swipe down,
you'll notice that the
expanded version actually
has that photo.
Lets you maybe share
the article.
And this is all very easy
to do from a developer
standpoint.
ADAM KOCH: There's a class
called NotificationCompat,
which I think we've mentioned
before, that allows you to
build these richer notifications
from newer
platform versions, but
remains backward
compatible with older versions.
Definitely good to use.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, super
trivial, I'd say, to use.
It's only couple
lines of code.
We're also working
on a template.
You could do File, New,
Notification, it'll just build
all this code for you.
So moving on, another quick
tidbit is if you're using a
web view for presenting
content, then you're
automatically going
to get this.
But if you're not, if you're
using a text view, by default,
your text will not
be selectable.
So if you long press on
the body content,
nothing will happen.
So there's a really
neat little trick
that you could do.
You could set a single attribute
on your text view--
and this is more for developers,
of course--
that makes that text
selectable.
And from there, you can
obviously customize.
You can say, allow people
to share this text or
copy it, and so on.
ADAM KOCH: And surprise,
surprise.
That attribute is called
Text Is Selectable.
Easy.
ROMAN NURIK: Very simple.
Let's keep moving on.
So this is the last step here.
This is what it looks like.
So you guys remember from the
very beginning, the very, very
beginning starting point was
it was just all over the
place, didn't look
good on a tablet.
The spacing was awful, it was
hard to pick out the articles
from each other.
The photos weren't
well aligned.
The typography was just
very bare bones.
And so with just a few tweaks--
and actually, all
these screenshots
are screenshots.
They're not Photoshop
mock-ups.
I think overall, it took
us a few hours to
put this all together.
Each one of these tweaks
is very incremental.
It's minor iteration, right?
It's not like a revolutionary
design by any means.
So with very little
work, I'd say, you
can get to this point.
So you should definitely
get to it.
With that-- unless you guys
have any final thoughts?
NICK BUTCHER: No.
I think it's been really awesome
to show the processes,
and the things that we think
about and look at in a
redesign, so hopefully
it's been--
ROMAN NURIK: Cool.
ADAM KOCH: Yeah, makes me want
to eat some bacon ASAP.
ROMAN NURIK: We're past
lunch, but I think
Nick is almost there.
Let's jump in to Android
Design News.
So we don't have too much
design news today.
Nick, do you want to start
with Gunther's blog post?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
So Gunther and the guys from
Apollo did a really, really
good blog post talking about
the importance and the
opportunity of using widgets
with your application.
I think they really summed up
the opportunity there for me,
that this is a prime piece of
real estate on the user's
device where much of their user
journeys start from, and
you get to show another avenue
for your content, and have a
really quick and easy
way to put stuff
on their home screen.
It's a shame when many
apps don't offer this
functionality.
So really think about how
widgets might work with your
app and your content.
ROMAN NURIK: Absolutely.
Next up, from Taylor,
we have the
Wireframe Screen Flow Template.
I'll briefly just
mention that.
It's very important to map out
the different interactions in
your app, not just
the visuals.
So when you touch this,
what happens?
When you pitch here or
double touch here or
swipe here, what happens?
And so this is a great starter
template for basically giving
you the different gestures that
you'd want to do, as well
as linking up different
screens using
these little red arrows.
So if you're starting from
scratch, you may want to just
start from this point if
you're mapping out the
interactions within your app.
NICK BUTCHER: It kind of
helps you think about
navigation as well.
So if you think you have
multiple routes into your
content to say, we've done a
widget for the bacon app we've
just been looking at,
you might come
into a detail screen.
So it helps you think about how
the hierarchy might work
as well, I think.
ROMAN NURIK: Absolutely.
Moving on--
so at this point, we should
talk about the different
communities out there.
So there are two communities,
and these are evidenced by our
two slides here.
There's the official Android
Design Community on Google+.
If you haven't joined it,
feel free to join.
There is an issue currently
with the community in the
sense that there's a lot
of spam and a lot
of off-topic posts.
We're currently exploring ways
in which we can make the
community more valuable,
provide more value for
everyday designers.
So definitely if you have some
questions or if you want to
start a discussion thread about
a certain topic, feel
free to post here.
NICK BUTCHER: There's
some design
topics in there as well.
So it's like design feedback
requests and so on,
[INAUDIBLE].
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
If you have any questions about
your design, if you want
folks in the general public to
provide comments on your
design, feel free to post
a few screenshots.
I'd avoid posting links to
apps, because that can be
viewed as kind of spammy, but
if you could post some
screenshots, folks generally
are good
about providing feedback.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
Most discussion seems at this
point around a specific
question, like, how do you feel
about my spacing on X,
kind of thing, rather than,
what do you think?
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
And then there's also the
Unofficial Android Designers
Community, which I believe they
have an approval process,
but it's fairly lightweight.
And this is more for
professional Android designers.
If you're doing design work for
a company, for a client,
or even for your own company
that you work for, and that's
your core job, this is a more
advanced, higher level
thinking community.
There's lots of good
content on here.
So I'd advise joining
both at this point.
And I think lastly, Kahil--
I'm going to butcher
your name, sorry.
Kahil Nettleton has posted a
PSD version of all of the
icons in the Action Bar
Icon Pack available on
developer.Androi
d.com/design/downloads.
He's posted that in
a PSD format.
So if you don't use Illustrator
or if you don't
have Illustrator, and you just
want the shapes in PSD format,
then this may be for you.
Actually, there is one more.
Michal has done a great job in
taking all of the slides from
episodes 1 through 12 of the
show-- basically everything we
did in 2012--
and putting them into
a single zip file.
So if you've wanted that--
if you don't feel like going
through all the Google+ posts
and fetching all the screenshots
and all that--
it's available in a single zip
file available on his Dropbox.
If he decides to take it off
his Dropbox, then sorry.
But he's done everybody a favor
in doing this, so thank
you, Michal.
I think that's our last slide.
With that, any parting
thoughts, guys?
NICK BUTCHER: Oh, one more
piece of news actually.
I forgot to add it into the
show, but I just saw it in one
of the screenshots from
the community.
If you're in London, there's
an event going on in the
Google Campus building on the
25th and 26th of January, so
next weekend.
Design and developers coming
together and talking about
designing for Android.
So if you can make it to London,
then check it out.
And for more information,
go to the London GDG--
the Google Developers Group.
Go to their Google+ page, and
you'll find all the details.
ROMAN NURIK: Cool.
ADAM KOCH: Great.
ROMAN NURIK: Well, thanks
for joining us in
Android Design in Action.
As always, I'm Roman Nurik.
ADAM KOCH: Adam Koch.
NICK BUTCHER: And
Nick Butcher.
ADAM KOCH: See you guys later.
ROMAN NURIK: See you.
Peace out.